side note the guy that showed up to this
wedding nicknamed the stun
gun thank you to our sponsor factor
factor is America's number one ready to
eat meal kit can help you fuel up fast
for breakfast lunch and dinner with Chef
prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
head to factor meals.com
dp50 and use the code dp50 to get 50%
off that's code dp50 at factor meals.com
dp50 to get 50% off guys we want to
thank our sponsor farity oh I love them
farity is a family brand founded by Alex
and his wife Carrie and his twin brother
Mike close to our hearts uh that
channels their love of the beach
lifestyle into clothing for life's
greatest moments fairity crafts clothes
that feel as good as a day at the beach
and they are backed by their guarantee
of quality love these guys farity has
giv doll dumb people time listeners an
amazing deal 20% off on your order head
to farity brand.com DPT use the code DPT
at checkout for 20% off your order
that's F A rty brand.com
DPT so I love certain casino games my
wife was just in Vegas and she just
played a slot machine at Old School pull
the handle she won 87 bucks I like
Blackjack because I can play for a
really long time and even even if I just
break even I feel like I've won because
I've had entertainment so guys download
the DraftKings casino app now sign up
with promo code DPT and new customers
get a deposit match up to $100 in Casino
credits when you deposit $5 or more only
on DraftKings casino with promo code
DPT hey toes welcome to another episode
of D people Town population you
population Craig Craig welcome to the
show dude a fan the pride of the pride
of Milwaukee the shame of Chicago the
shame of Chicago the pride of Milwaukee
and look he likes it that way he likes
it that way the flatness of that brim of
that hat it's just got to keep it crisp
scon got to be able to host a wedding on
this thing if it if something solid logo
like I it's an inner division rival of
ours and Dan's we're all rivals when it
comes to the NFC we're all friends when
it comes Dum people National League
Central National League National League
central we're all rivals and yet we can
sit here together and make comedy about
D people why can't they do it in the
Middle East do you feel like the Rivalry
has gone down card's Cubs just all of
them I don't feel the same vitriol now
that there's inter league play you don't
you don't play as many times right so
there aren't as many series and it's not
as like focused and concent you just
don't go as many pough fights as you
used to and that's yeah how many game
backs are the Cubs right now I don't
know they were like well they just
dropped three when we're recording this
but I think it was like a one and a half
and that's what the takes that you guys
so all I remember Jay and I saw comic I
wish I remember who this comic was he
was killing us we were maybe one of the
first standup shows we ever went to in
the 80s Carl leov maybe no it was
somebody who was he talked about being
at Wrigley Field and seeing somebody put
his kid cuz the kid couldn't reach the
trough up on the trough to pee and then
a drunk person accident knock into
the I've seen guys swim the trough no
stop that's dumb people Town well here's
the deal TR off Nate I we're going to
talk about all the stuff you got going
on nobody becomes a character better
than Nate
Craig so we've got dumb stories Daniel
let's jump into them okay you ready to
do this yes this was sent in by we
talking about practice at not a gamecore
three love all of our townies on the
ground and in the air send us Dum people
town at Dum people town uh right no it's
sclar brothers and Daniel
vankirk on Twitter here we go Uninvited
family member at funeral causes Havoc oh
boy Dan what do we tell you I just kind
the end speaks to the beginning Dan I
think
you we ended the way we started they are
who we thought they were yeah there's a
reason Uninvited sounds like sounds like
the fact I didn't get invited to this
wedding yeah
where did it really start let's Source
wedding and funeral there are show
somewhere I was drunk when I didn't get
the invitation you debate is it worse to
not invite them and deal with that
Fallout or invite them and just pins and
needles at the you got to manage
eggshell it the whole can you manage the
situation there are people we've have
these in well you guys are Missouri you
you just spend a lot of your night
looking over at them and be like okay
he's talking to Phil Phil should be fine
in this
you do invite him either way you got to
have a fixer you got you also have a
stay away you go hey Bob's coming if
Bobby shows up right yeah I want you
watching theame but then you have
another you run interference that means
you get it between him and Aunt Susie
there's a lot of get over there then you
go over to Uncle Scott and you go Bob's
coming do not talk to him I need you to
stay away stay away you see him you will
leave the room hey we're not having the
guns discussion we're not doing that
tonight we're not doing that tonight gun
what if he brings his guns we got to
talk about it I don't even want you in
the same line for electric slide you're
over there you stay in the front part I
told the DJ you get three requests you
stay by the DJ they said a little bit
louder
now I'll show you a little bit guy that
drunk guy at a wedding nobody's getting
low enough he's saying softer get lower
you I'm in charge of the limbo bar I'm
always in charge of the limbo bar I can
do both ends of it you go right
underneath my Clos during dinner Clos
during dinner you're not serving during
dinner do you guys have weddings like
that that's a big Illinois thing where
they will not close the bar during
during dinner oh that's a fight in
itself I thought you were saying
clothes no John Roy's wedding I talked I
gave the bartender a 20 handed me two
bottles of wine just you have to write
this book write the book how to be the
best wedding guest I'll dance with yourt
how to be the best wedding guest Dan
write it Dan if you don't write this
book we're going to write it ghost write
this I believe in you I believe I
believe you're right I believe I should
okay have you guys ever not gone to a
wedding because somebody else was going
to be there no uh no but and and that is
a through line to a person's life if
they say yes I have I have avoided a
wedding because somebody might be there
might were they there they were not
there and you didn't go you missed theed
go I missed the wedding go it was it an
ex it was not an ex it was uh some it
was uh it was someone you had beef with
somebody who was going downhill and I
was like it's if if I'm there and
they're there and that makes it chaotic
it's worse for the couple you didn't
think you could just not do it
Dan now my rule is if somebody shows up
who's hit someone in my family and
they're still coming I'm like hey just
so you know he if he talks to me it was
that level okay it was that level got
that side so this is Nate being
conscientious of whatever person this
story this person is all about a person
who's making a funeral about the a
massive brawl broke out during a funeral
for an elderly woman en Richmond this
comes from The Daily Beast she didn't
want that this is not what she wanted
what was meant to be an occasion to
celebrate the life of an elder woman in
Northern illino California NorCal yeah
turned into a e comical Mayhem after an
Uninvited family member stormed the
service storm the service everybody's
storing 6 I know Jes yeah you can't just
show up yeah do this eulogy without me
and you know they were not mentioned in
the obit which also pissed them off they
weren't listed in the survived by let me
see that thing right right right I love
a good obit okay here we
go the extraordinary sendoff happened in
the Contra Costa County Cemetery inside
Richmond's Rolling Hills Memorial Park
that just feels like a Costa is what
they called the Contra Costa that's the
mob in Sicily am I right you're
close Contra Costa is a version of the
classic Nintendo game
Contra Contra Costa County Cemetery
inside Richmond's Rolling Hills Memorial
Park I feel like I'm warming up for a
musical get ready you go on stage and
five Conta County Cemetery Richmond
Rolling Hills Memorial
Park you want to give it a tryed Le
yellow leather red Lea storming grandma
funeral in the Moonlight night night
watermelon watermelon try Contra Costa
County Cemetery Richmond Rolling Hills
Memorial Park you want to try it cont
cemeter Rolling Hill cemeter par both of
you got it almost right sure uh it was
here's the other thing the brawl the
sendoff the crazy Havoc was not
apparently
entirely unanticipated they knew it was
coming they time in the service a family
member brought a stun gun to the
services because of longstanding family
issues if you bring have to bring a stun
gun no if you're bringing a stun gun
you're going to use it this is by the
way this is like a new Foxworthy bit if
you ever bring a stun gun to a funeral
you might be in a decades long family RI
you might be in a few
right imagine that should I bring it
should I bring it bring it should I
bring it where did I just put it in the
Cary where's my stun gun I'm rolling by
the funeral don't put it in the car
because if it's in the car you're going
to wish you had it on you pepper spray
doesn't work on him we know this we know
that it is we're out of bear
spray put it in your purse H this guy
dude bring in a stun also you know what
that means there was a point in that
person's life where they were like I'm
just going to order it I'm going to
order it like you had just the process
of realizing you need to buy a stun gun
means enough it's getting old she's
going to die I'll probably need it let
me order it if you've brought it to the
stun gun you've definitely brought it to
if you brought it to a funeral this is
me being ignorant is a stun gun a taser
it's a taser it's a body to body oh but
it's not like here yeah t well use it
interchangeable I would say for these
purposes it's I think it's more easily
the Char charge
it oh yeah you can shoot a little proti
yeah but I don't think you can buy the
prongs very easily I think I think the
average person can buy the hey get out
of here cut to someone listening to this
being like Oh I know where you can get
the prong or cut to people being like
you can buy them both yeah El you can
buy them in bulk these guys are idiots
side note the guy that showed up to this
wedding nicknamed the stun gun funeral
for sure funeral stun gun they are they
are slightly interchangeable depending
on the luncheon sure okay and how fun
the person was and how much the richond
police department said it responded to
The Rolling Hills Memorial Park at 1:30
p.m. that was we're not going to guess
that cuz it's a funeral funeral after
several reports of a chaotic altercation
chaotic altercation you're on the radio
and you hear it's a chaotic altercation
several reports one of the most
dangerous jobs for police officers the
all the Good Apples is knocking on just
door knocking pulling somebody over
what's on the other side that is blank
Sate you know you're going into a
chaotic altercation that is anything
does this that does this qualify as a
domestic violence call because when it's
between like boyfriend girlfriend
husband wife those are very dangerous CS
yes and family stuff family stuff
domestic disturbance this is maybe
slightly less
dangerous I'm assuming gun in this case
they don't even need to say the over I
guarantee they didn't say domestic
disturbance over the radio they said the
name of the family and the cop knew all
he needed the Johnson Funeral chaotic I
need backup chaotic altercation between
H between up to how many family members
oh my God how many do you guys think got
in what do you think funeral you think
someone's already brought a stun gun you
think Uninvited Guest you think chaotic
altercation I just realized this there's
a lot of people at this funeral that got
this guy's back yeah which guy the guy
showing up the guy Uninvited that's
right so now you've got you got you got
factions yeah oh Jesus there's people
getting mad at the guy who brings the St
who brought it's not 18 on one that
wouldn't be chaotic no it's 18 on seven
yes there's there's 25 you say 25 people
I'm putting it at 25 25 put 17 17 14
14 chaotic altercation between up to 20
family members my God right some of whom
were reportedly armed of course of
course Sergeant Aaron pomoy you get
strapped great on the police basketball
team pom poms P yeah AP Sergeant Aaron
pomoy said it was an instance of family
drama that started between a brother and
a sister who were attending their
mother's funer funeral who did not get
along and quote it goes back many years
of course it does I have a you know
we're going to end it every family has
people that you're like I'm done yep and
for those at the funeral or a wedding
you or even Christmas you go if they're
if they walk through the door as I'm
passing through the foer or whatever
crossing the hall I'll say hey how are
you leave it that's it that's it that's
I would say don't even do that give a
little and that's it I think anything
coming out of your mouth is going to be
bad it's you're not even pointing to
them you're kind of over them you salute
above them yeah salute or you don't even
you do things that are like so so
General you're like oh look who's here
yeah but not to them hey you know it's
more people are here it's real wild
animal adjacent you don't want to look
them in the eye for right for a lot of
reasons too much one blink hold on side
note have you got one blink see that
silver back Tik Tok no so these
photographers were in the jungle uh
watching gorillas right and a storm came
through so everybody including them had
to like kind of search for shelter and
then they were in a little small little
clearing storm clears uh Apes start
coming out and because were they all
scattered you no longer knew you you you
didn't know your distance from any of
them and literally from me and Jason to
you two a silver back comes out there's
a guy where Nate is and he just like
stands there and he they I guess they
make a noise they fill some sort of like
chest cavity Sack or whatever before
they pound their chest and Hees he's
like and then he he goes and he like
walks by as soon as he clears the person
where Nate is this person this who
filmed the whole thing goes and now walk
over here and the person just slowly
like goes because they couldn't gauge
the they didn't know where any of them
were my God be freaking but it was like
what you were say we just like I'm just
going to let them walk through the door
and then I'll cross and I watched the
Tik Tok where there this woman at a zoo
or at some kind of zoo was pounding her
chest at the monkey or at the at the
silver back gorilla area giant thick
glass like in front of the thing and it
made the monkey the the gorilla go crazy
and was like running around and then he
jumps up and slams his hands on glass
and the glass cracks and you're just
like uh they're all going to die you did
a dumb thing you Domin a dominance thing
do not
engage same for this don't engage all
you tell is I'll put that Tik Tok [__] I
got you do not Eng do not engage that
goes for the wedding sometimes and the
funeral or the family get 20 people
fighting at this guy so anyway Bobby's
pounding his chest brother was brother
was not invited brother is the one who
was not inv
right of course of course uh the brother
and sister were talking and got into an
argument when her boyfriend came over
and encouraged her to walk away smart
bab bab just walk away but you know that
it was one of these just walk away from
this [__] pie that's right exactly
walk away he's not worth it nothing
never been worth it he shouldn't even
have been born just walk away he should
here be the bigger person he's not going
to don't talk to this human mistake he
should have been aborted just walk away
it's just that hey hey I'm trying to
break get up that guy your mom would
want you to stay away from this
loser look what look at the lengths your
mom went to get away from she grandma
didn't want us grandma didn't want to
see him here and you shouldn't see him
whatever he's talking to and like in
front of the guy revealing all the
things he feels about there's a reason
his family left just like roasting joke
roasting his kids don't even want to be
around him he's a cancer that's a that's
a version of the roast battle you vers
Jason but it's me defending you against
Randy and Nate defending Randy against
we're actually roasting this is the RO
of I'm roasting
Randy but it's like and we constantly
have to keep you back that' be so funny
and complicated
okay goes back many years the boyfriend
tries to the brother started beating on
the boyfriend and that's when it
escalated I would say it already did and
well and it became a brawl and we
started to get calls so multiple people
who aren't involved are like get out my
phone 911 there's a brawl happening at
the stun guys just running around
tagging both sides of the he doesn't
care he's just so excited to use the
dude the second this guy rolls up to the
funeral there are three or four people
at this funeral who hit 91 and they're
just waiting somebody might have done it
when they got out of the car 911 and
then I'm about to hit call there's a
whole room full of Sergey feder out
there 91 it's some point during the
physical fight the brother got into the
vehicle with the intention of driving
over his sister no so that's him I'll go
I'll go I'll go I'll go up Bui we're
already in Cemetery fires up the Buick
wow he attempted to drive towards his
sister in an aggressive way but instead
he struck another female and sent her to
the hospital with non-life threaten so
now her people are like oh okay you want
to [__] go and who knows what side
they're on out I'm glad you now the step
kids are involved sure in the car the
brother also damaged the grass the grass
the grass but but knocked over and
damaged head stones and bases and broke
a water man that ejected copious amounts
of water and flooded the funeral plot so
that's the open open plot is like for
her spraying in the air into the funeral
plot while people are fighting all
around so Grandma's going to just float
so as we all know this is like a onepage
for a fake viral video yeah exactly
that's all of these are this what you
got to do that's D people town is spoken
viral
videos uh anecdotal viral we all know I
was a Digger in Rochelle Illinois right
I will tell you riding lawn mow you
catch a any sort of gravestone they all
move so easily I mean enough that you
know a riding lawnmower and then you got
to [__] come around the corner back
them back into spot oh god um so he but
he knocked a whole bunch of them over he
hit a water man which then that's
shooting up into the air filling
Grandma's plot like fing
her we dropped in little Dan Dan Van
Kirk High School domino game that he
played over there in Ro knock it it goes
anybody's got any uh flames and roelle I
it's the opposite of the movie Fury I
just kept saying saddest job I ever had
and then uh where were we oh here we go
the driver also reportedly knocked over
the casket with the woman inside of it
obviously oh boy but but wait when did
we get this person's name guys it just
says someone's name they never cited I
think it's the boyfriend I think that's
there's a there's a there's a oh my God
it's there's a robin to the Batman of
this yeah oh no it's the no I'm sorry
it's not her name breaker I don't know
who that is Stone Breer that has to that
either better be the chief of police or
the person run Stone Breer no bone bre
bone bre
bone officer bone break but Stone
breaker said the body didn't fall out
which kind of makes me feel like it
definitely fell out and they like no no
no it's just an arm just an arm we got
it fall out when the brother got out of
the car why would you get out of the car
you're you're in your own weap you need
to drive away a family member hit him in
the head with a cane smart and you know
wasn't his Cane [__] like to his uncle
give me that cane give me that Aunt Ed's
lost her cane That's right hit him over
the cane injuring him pomoy said they
used the cane to try and get him under
control that's been his whole
life that's probably how we got here the
side note the cane is also how he got
out of control right ex use the cane to
I okay the uh they used the cane to get
him under control the suspect was hit a
couple of times the cane came from
someone who was at the funeral no [__] I
don't know that they ever identified
where the cane come from it's not a
magic cane this isn't Moses's staff
produced at this point the you know the
journalist is having fun here also the
reason they're saying is not because we
can't figure out who had the cane is
because too many people had canes so we
don't know whose cane it was and they
all look the same we sometimes get
family disputes at the cemetery or at
the church Stonebreaker said
Stonebreaker has to be the person
running the funeral right this is no
different or the guy driving the car he
himself is a head if Graves what you do
with a back ho Stonebreaker is a great
name that's a great name this was no
different but it was especially large
family fight and they said possibly
armed this one went above and beyond
usually you don't get the injuries in
this case it looked like they had some
really bad blood which was no longer
pumping no shots were fired and no guns
were found hey so you know what on that
alone I will say I love a good just
Outsiders fight fight yeah no shot I
love a good we The Outsiders the soas no
shots were fired no guns were found
sounds like a Leonard skard lyric stay
golden Stone breaker the brother from
Bayo was arrested for felony assault
with a deadly weapon and vandalism pomoy
said the Contra Casta County District's
Attorney office hey is reviewing the
charges Rolling Hills Memorial Park said
it could not comment on the incident as
it's under police investigation police
said preliminary estimates from the park
suggest the fight cost $20,000 in damage
we'll get out of here on this how old
how old is the brother
we know the fight's going back years you
know canes were involved a car was
involved we know a boyfriend was
involved but people have late life L
life boyfriend this is a late the hell
you're goingon to like that it could
have been that kind of I'm her boyfriend
I'm her boyfriend and I've seen I I
[__] I I fought the Koreans and I
Koreans and I the Koreans during the
Vietnam War I love that you can't put
boy in front of your I think he's 61 61
from Randy scar I know for a fact he's
the older brother
okay
um they always loved you someone said
that I think he's way younger than 61
okay because they're not scared of a 61y
old okay they're scared who's they the
family well once he gets in the car I
know but keep going I want you to say
with your Vine say with your Vine ride
it down but they got you know they got a
taser he's never done the car thing
before right oh I'll do it this time
I'll do the he's not going to get in the
car he's not get the car go get
the and and the boyfriend's like take my
[__] keys do my car you never get the
car you can't drive do my car he
threatened it so many times you done so
many whippets you lost control hours
later the fight's over that guy's like
where's my keys I threw them at him we
were over here you supp what are you
going with n I'm saying he's I'm saying
he is
a 34 year old man okay J uh 56 56 yeah
okay get your answ your
brother taking out Stones popping water
man Knocking Dead women's caskets over
Stone Breer love a love a mortician with
a stage name by could have been the cop
to either way yeah fighting with the CIS
punching the brother
is 36 years
old get to that pin scary get to that
what a scary age I mean that's almost
the
age that's almost Mass shooter age I
mean right it's like Mass anger him in
the but anger the anger hasn't all the
way you know he's still keep it in the
family that's when people go crazy 36 it
changes a lot of what you think is being
because a lot of said you don't need to
do this you don't need to older they're
like get the hell out of here yeah not
only am I blaming my life on my family
I'm blaming it on society as well I'm
blaming my family on societ in the
family uh ry's going to have story too
I'm going to have some plugs can I say
we'll be right back we'll be right back
we'll be right
[Music]
back people Town hey gang welcome back
to dumb people town with the great Nate
Craig before we get into what Nate
Craig's doing where you can see him live
he's got great tour dates coming up
Daniel tell them what people oh my gosh
go to Daniel van kirk.com I got a little
bit of Wordpress help remember I was
saying that so now you can see all my
dates at once other changes and good
things will be happening but go to
daniel.com for all all of my dates I
don't know exactly when this is dropping
but I guarantee I'm on the road probably
somewhere in the East Coast or maybe in
the midwest I will tell you the yuck
Festival in Boston is going to be a
great thing I'll be with our Buddy Hayes
in North Carolina at Raleigh first time
I'm headlining in Raleigh and that'll be
at the theater there the Rialto but
really if you want to catch the good run
friends I'm going to be doing Louisville
Indianapolis and rochell that'll be like
the 8th 9th and 10th rochell show 7:00
already sold out we're adding the nine
you can get those but on Saturday 11:11
my special the rose gold hour with me
Daniel vankirk is at the Lincoln Lodge
two shows by this point I guarantee that
early show is sold out so get your
tickets for The Late Show and if you're
a if you're a Towny let me know I'll
probably tell you where the Afterparty
is going oh for all those shows my last
quick thing townies come out bring a
headline I'm going to open every show by
asking any townies if they have a
headline and if you're a pen pal and you
you've come over here or vice versa
bring a postcard too I'd love to talk to
people as I open every single show
Daniel van kirk.com but more importantly
Nate Craig hot [__] special taping at
the Lincoln LOD that's awesome go see
that everybody that's one of my favorite
clubs anywhere I'll be there you're
special can we just say for one second
you're special taped in Chicago as well
at the Green Mill at the Green Mill yeah
live at the Green Mill new one the new
one the new new the new new off the
presses beautifully shot it looks like
it was shot in like the 1920s that place
has like a 20s vibe to it it's like the
old Al Capone hangout or whatever
can't believe I got to shoot it there I
love that you did it there thank you
amazing I really appreciate what about
dates dates um uh September 29th and
30th I'll be at the Ann Arbor comedy
showcase please come see me there free
tickets for UAW members those tickets
are get on those uh would be honored to
have you um and then I will be at
hilarities in Cleveland November 16th
through the 18th I'll be at the Turner
Ballroom in Milwaukee Wisconsin giving
Eve November 22nd uh very special guests
on that show and drive up just to watch
come come hang bro come do a set we
might have Dan vankirk you
just 20 minutes from the Hub City um
Madison Wisconsin at the Majestic on
December 27th The Laughing tap in
Milwaukee um December New Year's Eve
weekend and then um and then I will be
at the Lincoln Lodge January 5th and 6th
and I'll be out with Bill Burr in
October so come find me how consume the
special though consume the special all
things comedy YouTube channel Nate
craig.com um you'll find me watch it
it's free you'll love it leave a comment
positive send to other people that's how
good people like this get to go do more
comedy that is the hot move uh if people
want to that is really does project in
the algorithm and I don't know if com
people are you guys got such good fans
I'm sure they already know this but like
liking and commenting just catapults
something it helps every vide this video
I'll just tell people because it shows
the algorithm people must like this
because other people have liked and
especially commented so then they push
it into other people's you know what
also also shows the algorithm what this
next story you guys ready yeah algorithm
gets in fight yeah algorithm gets in
fight at uh baby at baby christening
ready algorithm Story number two sent in
by carlen mcder at alen gthm Allen
gthm so he was at the zoo and he there
has to be an Al algorithm gorilla them
Rory and I were just saying there has to
be a jack mehoff sure for definite there
was an oral sex into Kel
Illinois uh send him by carlen mcdermid
at she car welcome back girl here's the
headline man thrown out of McDonald's
for outfit that left Diner quote
completely horrified you could have
stopped at McDonald's I mean do you know
what you have to do you know what you
have to do to get kicked out of
McDonald's of a McDonald's right wow so
here's the deal I am G to just say this
about this story and you guys are going
to have to help me through this I don't
know who to be mad at I really don't
you're having your own who I pinball
around and I'm in say the headline one
more time man throw out a McDonald's for
outfit that left diners quote completely
horrified so we're going to find out
about the outfit we're going to find out
but there are parts of this country
where there's they're so [__] you
know let everybody let everybody do
whatever they want stop telling me what
to do unless I don't like what you're
doing so there are people who could get
kicked out of McDonald's in parts of
this country for wearing a Slayer shirt
right so this is we're going to find out
about all this shall we get into it yeah
a man who leads a Barefoot lifestyle
okay I'm already I'm already out first
of all that's not an outfit that does
not if that if you're going to tell me
that's an outfit I don't care if [__]
chest that's not an outfit M I'm mad at
the headline do the drivethru you
dumbass do the drivethru or walk through
the drivethru in your
godamn you you guys pedicured at least
once a year yeah well I have not
pedicure I need to I support this man's
Barefoot lifestyle I got your gift are
you wait are you a pedicurist no for
yourself no I I I I mean all three of
you got gifts coming so wait by the way
that is should be and when the strike
ends I want to pitch a show cuz remember
the Mentalist which was just that he's a
that he uses his mind to solve Crim
unlik any other detective I wanted a
detective to be called the pedicurist he
solves all crimes while talking to the
person person it's really disarming but
it opens like CSI Miami looks like this
person was one step ahead it's all it's
all foot stuff look like they had a toe
in the dessert he had a foot on each
side of the line yeah they have to be
okay okay I'm I'm way out on this
lifestyle shunning shoes was thrown out
of a branch of McDonald's a branch it's
not a public of America oh McDonald's
this isn't this isn't part of the Harold
Washington Library I'm sorry which
McDonald's oh the thorn Hill Branch
great okay so the branch of McDonald's
after ordering his food so he was
allowed to order his food yeah well they
don't I mean the counter prevents James
Graham was in McDonald's it is a it's
where poor people keep their money in a
branch McDonald in the branch they make
deposits was in McDonald's in ravenside
retail Park in beex Hill Sussex this is
England Reta retail Park in back this is
what I do to prepare for my theater
ravenside retail Park beex Hill Sussex
when he said he was told to leave
shortly after sitting down the and I'm
not going to say how old he is widower
now are we on his side now we're back on
his side am I mad at mcdonal soed my
shoes I to McDonald's I went to
McDonald's in ravenside and ordered my
food minding my own business six hash
browns do
not what do you mean you're need my
sh M my own business I just sat down
waiting for table service table
service I me kind of a branch of
McDonald's is it if you're doing
something like I was waiting for Bal
service Chop Chop if you're doing
something that is outside the norm which
will at the very least draw attention
and and the and very possibly draw
ridicule are you minding your own like
even if you're a woman with a tit out
are you minding your own business I'm
not saying anybody should you know
physically cost you obviously but like
you are going to get somebody going hey
with the boob let's you're out just so
you know you're out minding my own
business
is a very subtle way of saying it's
other people's problems I'm doing fine
and I and I knew it's you're right it's
a way of owning that you brought these
cards to the table but you're mad how
other people play them I'm just it'sing
my own business Dan it's the I'm sorry
you offended by my behavior that's not
an apology that's not an apology apology
I'm sorry you couldn't handle what I was
I'm sorry that you're an apology is I
shouldn't have done that I'm sorry I'm
sorry that you don't like that this
McDonald's smells like me
now or this
McDonald start selling corn chips I send
I've said to offended people after a
show I'm sorry you didn't like it and I
do mean it cuz I and you're right I'm
not sorry for what I said but I am sorry
that it you did not enjoy the show I
would rather everybody enjoyed the show
you need to leave I'm sorry you can't
handle the truth that's bad yeah you
want you want my feet on that wall my
name of is I just sat down waiting for
table service when one of the service
people came up and said that I could not
be in there without shoes first of all
service people service people service
people non robots non non LTD I
questioned her about this and she said
the words no shoes no shirt no service
right right nothing wrong with that
still out on this guy to which I told
her that was an old saying from hippie
times in the USA used to restrict people
from going into places now you love
this everywhere a my hair up under hat
and I went into ask him why but that is
true times that is true but we we also
realized it was one we were going to
keep what's that a [__] James Joyce
poem but okay but let me just say this
I'm not defending the guy but there was
a time Randy and I were trying to write
a bit about this Rhymes in this McDonald
I guess to be fair nobody said his feet
are disgusting and that's what I'm
picturing picturing
disgusting two things one we everyone
wears flip-flops people's feet are out
all the time that's
one two there was a time in this country
where you could like if you walked a dog
too close to a restaurant the owner
would come out and be like get out of
here we have an a rating get your dog
don't walk in by the patio now people
carry their dogs into five-star
restaurants and sit them down on the
floor you can't have a dog in a
restaurant Flor or hold them on the
table chair table give them a table you
a dog in and around the food you cannot
do that that is unsanitary as un
sanitary as a guy without at the same
time like if all your chairs are bolted
down what are we really going for you
said that before if you can clean if you
can clean the whole place with just a
host it's not a restaurant it's not a
restaurant choose optional if the menu
is on the wall as like a thing like in
it's lit up that that's not if you're
pressing if you're pressing a button on
a cash register that's the picture of
the item that's not a I'll be done in a
moment go fire up your pressure washer
fire up the
pressure
McDonald right by a beach you're going
to get people with no shirt no Dan just
said it though you're right if you put a
McDonald's by a beach you're going to
get a lot of no shoes and no shirts and
no shirts and this island you put one in
relle we're going to be like the [__]
you doing so but she was having none of
it she went to get the manager who said
I may cut myself if you're walking
around you might cut yourself I'm like
that's true is there sharp so he's
talking about the reliability he said he
thought the incident was a bit silly as
he added he was sitting right next to a
play area which James said was often
full of barefoot children playing so
he's like well now he's got now he's
like I'm now claiming that I'm part of
the and I would say to them and if you
want to become a small child and go into
the play area we've got no problem how
old are you if you walk into that play
area you're arrested right that's like
that's like saying like well why can't I
be in the bride's dressing room there's
plenty of women who are her friends in
there yeah why can't I poop in my pants
that baby just did it baby just did it
baby just did it I'm a bad guy you get a
diaper you can poop wherever you want
technically you I mean it's it just the
poop the baby keeps the poop in one
place a little bit better than you do
he's going to have Shooters that's right
you're a lot of blowbacks yeah it's like
the Kenedy Association multiple Shooters
all right here we go I he said I spoke
to the head office and emailed them they
said it was down to the franchise
manager on the site so I love that the
head office of McDonald's is like hey
man that's your call your call cuz they
got beaches out of our McDonald this
this is D Beach McDonald's but also you
do know if if they don't say anything
and he cuts himself right he can and
then he sues his lawyer is going to go
these employees knowingly allow this man
in here and did not tell him to leave
the premises thereby making him feel and
he could he was ensured that he would
not cut his foot they are at fault
nobody told me this coffee would be hot
so I SP I want you to be a McDonald's
lawyer if you read all that that hot
that coffee was about 10 times hotter
than ever should be doesn't matter lady
don't get the Cofe it's strange to make
these decisions in a split second when
I'm doing no harm to anyone so now his
problem is with how quickly this the
decision was made it might have not been
made quickly this might have been talked
about hey should we allow people have
bare feet in here I think it's not a
problem and then someone else is like I
think it is a problem let's have a
discussion about it guess what no bare
feet in here he's filing he's doing what
Trump does he's filing for uh uh what do
you call counter counter suing all right
so he's in 2013 I had a life-changing
experience my wife passed now I'm on its
side and since then I've just been
living life life is too short to he's
happy she's passed life is too short to
not do things you think you might want
to do you think you might want to do
James said he has run 20 marathons in
his bare feet so now that to me seems
like I've done a marathon in these I'm
cool to go back being gross too Barefoot
lifestyle yeah I mean but they let him
order Barefoot life you just can't eat
in here right he ran the East he ran the
eastor half half marathon last Sunday
and is planning to run the London
Marathon this year sans's shoes he added
his Barefoot lifestyle has had mixed
reactions in the public of course James
said some are completely horrified and
don't understand horrified come on other
people fully support it and say they
wish they had the courage and freedom to
do it Courage and freedom going a little
too far uh nobody has said I wish I had
the courage and let me ask you this guys
what Freedom this guy shows up to to
your uh grandma's funeral or your
wedding bareo barefoot in parking lots
all yours yeah you can stand back there
get your taser out and get the cane
parking lots all yours wouldn't you go
come on what are we doing buddy what are
we doing today he McDonald I wear I
don't wear these shiny ass shoes every
day you you you don't wear shoes every
day Graham didn't wear didn't live a a
shoeless lifestyle she wore she lived a
shoed lifestyle lifestyle so so this is
the the equivalent of a person saying I
don't eat fish or I or I'm a vegetarian
and maybe there is a vegetarian so they
bring food to a wedding to like instead
of just eating the salad and eating some
bread and then having the dessert I'm
sorry you had I'm sorry your choice at
your wedding is this so I'm going to
take out a whole meal that I brought in
b
I wish those people would do say run it
back to the kitchen they'll played it
for you cuz then at least we're bringing
it out it looks like here theory on this
that is going here's my the on this dumb
guy D write it and put it in the book I
should here's my theory on this dumb guy
he is essentially Halle Berry from
Monsters ball and he wants McDonald's to
be Billy Bob Thorton right his wife's
dead he just needs to feel something and
so he's going to go in here and get in a
fight he's Charlie Theon from mon he
knows that every Marathon has to clear
him first of all his wife was wrong
about his toes okay let's just start
there his wife you said I had Hammer
feet he's got very nice toes and they
deserve to be free and enjoyed quite
frankly stay Barefoot pony boy that's
what she said to him stay Barefoot and
so he said she said him put on some
shoes or I take my own life a McDonald
spok here a taser a McDonald spokesman
now has to release a statement about
this how happy was he that I got to
write this at McDonald's we want to
create a welcoming environment for all
of our customers to enjoy their
experience the beex hill team informed
the customer that for his own safety and
for the comfort of other diners all
customers are asked to wear Footwear in
the restaurant when he refused the
customer was allowed to remain on this
occasion and finish his food before
leaving so they're like we did is he
even complaining about that why is he
complaining so he sent all those emails
I would have written back and been like
did they kick you out and he goes I
wasn't kicked out and then you go oh
cool take have a good day I got to go
back to the uh headline here uh just the
description of the other customers
reaction horrified one also add his
wouldn't it be is it lack of outfit
outfit yeah shouldn't it be lack of
outfit yeah or just it is Footwear
appearance appearance all right
horrified and also we haven't heard from
One customer being we got to hear from
another customer this all this guy's
Yelp review just this guy's Yelp review
going get out we're going to get out of
here on this I think I ha the journalist
the most exactly I hate the the person
wrote this story how old is the
widower because you feel like he's an
old cuss but he's running marathons
right so I'm going to think is but also
he said I'm now living life makes think
he he was in a prison of his wife's
design and now that she's gone to put
him above 52 I'm going to put him up
there because I think running marathons
well I mean he just didn't realized he
he didn't realize what his full his uh
potential was thank you how old is he
I'm going to say he is
I wouldn't pay put about 52 go for it go
for it you're for you're the guest 52 I
I think that's a pretty good number yeah
I like it I like it 52 I was 50 early
50s 52 fine I'll take 52 do think 43
Daniel I don't want the reason I don't
want to make him young is cuz CU you
don't want a young person
dying although he could have old time
exactly I mean that a beautiful could
have robbed the Cradle he is 47 years
old 47
43352 get your answers in Towes we come
back we'll give you let you know what
we've got going I almost thought you say
we'll give you the answer I was like man
we've never we've never hard teased like
that no people will Riot get your
answers in you know what this funeral be
like if you do that the be bring their
tasers and your canes cuz the Barefoot
Contessa the Barefoot Contessa the
Barefoot run the Barefoot Runa right is
55 years
old CG having a day can I get an assist
yeah for sure 100% that is uh he Craig
having a day jay give us a little teaser
of what we're going to have in segment
three let just say you can't count the
marathons I run on my toes anymore right
also he could have ran them 15 oh he's
doing it Barefoot and I feel like he
started that after di still she's 2013
so she passed unless she was 15 20 years
older dancing with his naked ass toes on
his wife's grave every day of his life
probably people who are like put your
feet in the sand like he's getting dad
what the [__]
godamn shes on for the first time in my
life I feel
free you want me to walk through the
drive-thru at McDonald's this is
banshees of in a b of in AAR also have
you seen a Flor in a McDonald's do you
want your bare fet on that I just like
walking through the syrup saying weak he
don't know what's on he wants the
disturbance I read I read a study once
they're the cleanest of all restaurants
the cleanest of all restaurants I like
my feet on the mine is a quick little
story about maybe the most brilliant
dummy and dumy I love it brilliant dummy
and dummy Town Nate craigs with us we
got one more segment stay
[Music]
here hey guys I want to talk to you
about our friends at faity clothes faity
brand clothes they're the best I every
day I'm lifting up my leg and showing
you the uh Legend sweatpants that I'm
wearing Jay's wearing a sweatshirt you
wear that on stage all the time we wear
fairity clothes at least one piece of
fairity clothing every single day why
because they craft clothes that feel as
good as a day at the beach and they're
backed by fairy they're just so good
backed by their guarantee of quality
they stand behind everything they make
these are pieces of clothing you will
have for many many years our entire
closets are filled with this stuff this
fall we're all in on the fairy laidback
Vibes that meets the classic styling
just got a they have the softest
flannels ever the legend sweater
flannels are the greatest softest things
ever I got a Blazer that I absolutely
love they I got the pants look like
denim but feel like sweats I got the
Chino the oh the chinos are the greatest
things I've ever had they're so soft and
comfortable and stretchy I love these
clothes like when my kids go I got the
rugby style shirt when my kids and my
wife go what do you want for Father's
Day I'm like you don't even to ask just
go to farity and get birthday farity
what do you treat yourself I love
supporting them too because it's twin
brothers it's a family business they're
wonderful people this is a great great
way to support a great brand that has
unbelievable clothes that last for years
and years and years how do we know we
are customers of this brand without even
having before they even sponsor the
podcast I said I have the legend sweat
pants on the legend sweater shirt made
with 95% lower impact fibers less
plastic less fossil fuel com uh
combustion they they take into account
the environment these guys are socially
conscious and very cool so here's what
we're going to do farity is giving all
dumb people Town lists an amazing deal
you ready 20% off on your order that's
incredible head to fairity brand.com DPT
use the code DPT a checkout that's F A
rty brand.com DP T guys picture this you
step into a world of non-stopped action
and you can do it on DraftKings Casino
play the classics like Blackjack
roulette and Slots plus enjoy exclusive
games that you cannot find anywhere else
right now new customers can get a
deposit match up to $100 in Casino
credits when you deposit $5 or more all
you got to do is sign up use the code
DPT make your deposit and start playing
from a full Suite of games this is so
much fun your way is the only way to
play on draft is there anything more
exciting than playing this lot of the
casino I absolutely love it so much my
wife was just in Vegas I love it just
won 87 bucks DraftKings online I love
this casino safe secure reliable so you
can deposit and withdraw your cash
whenever you're ready I love it so much
and and we to play Blackjack on your
phone that would be so much fun roulette
how about roulette there's just the
excitement of the ball spinning around I
love it so much and DraftKings makes it
super easy for you to do this I love the
match the money match they give for you
it's just fantastic it's fun and I like
that they're supporting this podcast so
tell them what to do Randall I'll tell
you what to do download DraftKings
casino app now sign up with promo code
DPT and new customers get a deposit
match up to $100 in Casino credits when
you deposit $5 or more only on
DraftKings casino with a promo code DPT
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler
Michigan New Jersey Pennsylvania West
Virginia please play responsibly in
partnership with Hollywood Casino at
Charles toown races in West Virginia all
games regulated by the West West
Virginia lottery in Connecticut help us
available for problem gambling call
8887895118
in Casino credits which require one-time
playthrough within 7 Days see terms at
casino. DraftKings
/pl Choice restrictions apply okay gang
the busy fall season already in swing
you might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for jam-pack days I
know our days your kids are at practice
and they got to do after school stuff
and how do you figure out a time to
actually make meals that are really good
you're too busy to cook in the fall too
the night the night time is coming
quicker on you I want to talk about
Factor cuz they're amazing I love that
they're sponsoring us cuz we love their
meals it's America's number one ready to
eat meal kit they help you fuel up fast
for breakfast lunch and dinner with Chef
prepared dietician improve approved
ready to eat meals delivered straight to
your door save time eat well stay on
track with your healthy lifestyle I want
to talk about this because I I know ry's
wife is an amazing cook uh and my wife
cooks a little bit and I cook a little
bit but we're not as good as she is all
right this is perfect for you the
problem for us is we make the same four
things over and over and over again in
our lives until Factor jumped in right
now Factor's in the mix and I'm eating
variety of amazing gourmet meals that
are incredible that my kids like and
they're so psyched because they're like
waa this is something we've never had
before poblano beef uh yeah cranberry
pecan chicken and apple Dion pork chop
ready in Just 2 minutes satisfy your
fall Cravings my mouth is watering as I
say this during a busy season without
hassle level up with Gourmet plus
options prepared to Perfection by my
Chef's ready to eat and record time
treat yourself to upscale meals with
premium ingredients like broccoli leaks
truffle butter and asparagus
the dieticians approve all this stuff we
love it Dan I are huge huge Factor fans
and I know Dan is too all right so head
to factor meals.com
dp50 use the code dp50 to get 50% off
that's code dp50 at factor meals.com
dp50 to get 50%
off hey guys welcome back to the show
before we jump into I just know we had
commercials but I loved your outro I
love
where you guys at what are you doing so
hey we got a lot stuff we're going to be
in Fort Collins never been to the comedy
Fort so excited October
6 is that amazing David Rodriguez so
good one of our uh fans is going to take
us to play golf I'm so the Fort Collins
Country Club I'm so excited quick dumb
question balls move farther up there
they do oh they will I'm sure May it's
like they put all the balls in think
they put all the balls including mine in
a
humidor so uh
so uh we got there on the 6 sth we we're
going to be in Springfield Missouri uh
on nth Blue Room Blue Room I'm very
excited to do that on the 10th and 11th
of uh November we might be doing our
Twan show which was called twin dads it
might be called crazy you guys are in
Missouri on the 10th and 11th I'm in
Rochelle Rory's up in Minneapolis
Patton's in Madison Sickler's in bavia
we're all comedy is getting out there so
we're going to be doing we might be
doing the uh Twan show that we did here
in La at the New York Comedy Festival
we're sort of working on getting the
Sunday encourage everyone to go out to
that and then we'll be at hilarities on
the uh 1 December 1st and
second and then uh we're in Seattle
we're in Portland at uh at uh helium on
January 4th and then the 5ifth we're in
Seattle at the crocodile just booked
we're going to do sou The Comedy Works
South that uh final uh that weekend in
January
February there's so much stuff Markley's
Comedy Castle doing tag it we'll do
another one one of those things that to
me I really and it feels good to be able
to guarantee this and also because you
guys are friends but you remember you
could it's still a great time but a
Heyday of of like six seven years ago
you'd be like you're in town go to roast
battle right yeah you'd have that
confidence right which you still totally
can sure but newer on the scene and just
as great is telling people like go to
tag it go to tag it go to tag it cuz the
lineup's going to be [__] great going
to see comedy uh comedians being friends
you're going to get a Green Room Peak
and you're going to see some people's
jokes get build if somebody was at my
moon tower show uh years ago with you
guys they were there seeing when the
rhetorical bit that ended up on the
album was tagged by you it's so fun last
night last night we did at Largo and it
was Patton and Sarah you look into
certain places you know pick and choose
late night
Saturday local tag it and you do it with
or late night Thursday but you know what
you could do for those Comics so fun
really fun you know one of the best
things when you go to a city and some
Comics are like I'm working on this and
you're like here I've been two years in
this is what you need to you know like
it' be like kill Tony but cool
right I love that I like my favorite
moments of Gilton is when they're like
let me give you we used to do that on
that show I know me too I got told was
rip somebody and then we'd be like okay
yeah one for two but and you guys could
do that local tag it local tag it but we
have one on November 6 we got another
one October 13th or is that what it is
October 13th yeah or 18 sorry 18th at
sorry I didn't mean to trash other
podcast but that's that's so hot right
now podcast on podcast violence N I
can't do it I love that I love that show
anyway uh let's that's suers scar.com
Jade go let's take us home all right uh
here's the headline man steals back ho
which I want to be a person I to be a
person man steals back ho for I'm not
going to tell you how long fight no for
how long the drive is Dan you know the
backhoe right is that what you used to
dig used to so man steals backhoe for a
certain mile drive to Illinois airport
to catch flight Dam we could have play
whose State this it's okay Illinois
airport to catch a flight a it's more
our area than yours though Dan a
Southern Illinois man has been charged
with theft for allegedly stealing a BHO
to drive about how many miles a [__]
this is quck airp to catch a flight
authorities said do you just leave it at
the front there and just get off of it
and go you you stole it you can leave it
the red zone is for immediate parking of
backos uh what do you what do you say
how many miles did he steal and drive
this backo I can't believe this I would
have never guessed Illinois but you know
he's on the
shoulder you wouldn't guess Southern 11
miles 11 miles R what are you going with
Nate you want to go last I'll go in a
back ho I'm I'm going go three and a
half three and a half miles yeah it's
down there I I'm going to to the airport
though Airport's far I don't know where
it is but it's I'm going to say he went
I'm going to say he went uh five miles 5
miles so 3 and 1 half 5 11 one of you is
one mile off do you guys 10 miles 10
miles six miles two and a half get your
answers in shot at your ham radios mhm
10 Mile
Drive 10 mes I can tell you why you're
late to the airport Drive why would you
take a backo slow it's slow driving
exactly uh security camera footage shows
a Carbondale manb ding part arriving at
veterans airport of Southern Illinois a
top of backo and leaving it in the
airport parking lot Thursday nobody hey
old adage nobody tickets a BHO that's
right where you going to put it true
where you going to put it on the on the
does even have a VIN does it have does a
BHO have a wiper a windshield wiper no
Dan does it have can you stick it in the
thing in the back no you could sh it to
the if you're cheating on your side
piece with another woman that should be
your back back you got a side piece and
a back side you're cheating on your side
piece with the back ho that's what I
mean right uh all right footage caption
of the man walking across the street
from the lot to the airport Lobby this
is my favorite detail of this I love
that he pulled in a lot favorite detail
of this carrying a guitar
case Bob Seager I need to know don't you
don't put me in a box you can't guess
who I am you don't know who I you had
better be Bob
Seager you do this in 1971 and it
becomes legendary you aren't even
arrested they're like you believe this
remember when Jim cochi stole that
backhoe and drove it to I his
operator I
wonder it makes the rambling all the
more impressive it totally does it
totally does the owner of I want his
name to be Edmund Fitzgerald oh the rec
of The Edmond Fitzgerald the owner of
the backhoe arrived at the airport a
short time later he probably walked was
right behind it the whole way my back
hole uh short time later and identified
the equipment as belonging to his
company the sheriff's office said the
owner said the machine typically used to
move large debris or men with guitar
cases yep move them down the street i'
been parked at a job site of course so
this guy hops on the thing but like you
leave the keys in like how does that
work I love that he knew how Tove the
back was there a key or was it a push
starter or no there's a key I mean well
one we so then whose fault is it don't
leave the keys in the back ho well but
then I mean if you ever lost the keys to
the back ho that's true Brian will have
your balls that's right we can't make
those down at the hardware store what do
you think he was doing I'll walk to the
airp he's you got to go to you got to go
to Caterpillar get keys just get a lift
but the I mean to me there on some level
it's amazing that this guy decid was
going to make a flight I know but it's
so rock he I think he made his fight
great planning uh got out of there Bundy
That's pretty rock and roll to like
steal a back get to the airport for what
I'm saying this would have been
legendary in the 70s or 60 we be telling
the
story I think it's John Mayer I I'm not
saying
it's why don't we
steal why don't we
steal into the airport all right you
guys that's it the show hey Nate Craig
go see him live and go check out his
special which is called live at the
Green Mill come see me and Ann Arbor
back hos love you guys love you guys and
oh [__] we got to get back to
[Music]
work